don't be afraid of success
a lot of us as entrepreneurs sabotage
ourselves
we have huge opportunities in front of
us but we don't take action on it
because we're afraid when you're going
for success you're going to have to
stretch yourself you're going to have to
do things that are outside your comfort
zone
and that is scary
i'm making this video as a response to
one of my youtube viewers dieter who's a
great dieter thank you so much for all
the comments you're leaving on the
videos who wrote in
evan can you make a video about the fear
of success
thank you and it's true
you're going to have to do things
that are scary
to get your business to where you want
it to be and it's only a limiting
personal belief that you have
so you get a huge order that comes in a
huge potential order
entrepreneurs may say oh that's that's
that's too big in order i i can't handle
that what if something goes wrong
or if you get an opportunity to be in
front of the media get on the camera do
an interview
a lot of entrepreneurs say oh i'm not
good in front of the camera
i can't do that i'm gonna i'm gonna make
a fool of myself
i can't do public speaking i'm not going
to go and do that presentation i can't
hire somebody
i'm not i don't want to be a manager
we're constantly
falling down to our own limiting self
personal beliefs
and as long as you believe those things
you're going to sabotage your success
you have to unblock those
you have to realize
that to get what you want
you're going to have to stretch it's
going to be painful it's going to be
scary but it's all possible
it's all within you
to reach your dreams
so if you're afraid of something
take some time
look yourself in the mirror
sleep on it
and think is this really something i
should be afraid of
or is it just a limiting personal belief
and i'm holding myself back
anything that you want
if you believe in it
you can accomplish it
so believe for those of you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below and i'd love to hear from you
if you have a comment on this video or a
question for your business please leave
it in the section below thank you guys
i'll see you soon